c'était le 6 janvier dernier un homme
est retrouvé mort dans son cabanon ici à
et moulins pas très loin degrés et
surtout une centaine de mètres de
l'endroit où avaient été retrouvées deux
mois plus tôt le corps d'alexia d'aval
l'enquète conclure à un suicide par arme
à feu mais jean marc florand l'avocat
des parents d'alexia se pose des
questions sur ce suicide
elle va demander ce que l'adn de ce
monsieur qui a mis fin à ses jours
soient comparées avec les adn retrouvée
à proximité du corps d'alexia ses autres
fragments d'adn qui n'appartiennent pas
à de nathan d'aval alors à qui
appartient-il la science a finalement
parlé et il n'y a aucun lien adn entre
le suicide et des moulins et la scène de
crime ont été retrouvé le corps d'alexia
et nous apprenons également que les adn
de grégory gay le beau-frère tout comme
celui de stephanie la soeur ou des
parents d'alexia n'ont pas été
retrouvées non plus à proximité du corps
la provenance de ces autres adn serait
lié à un phénomène naturel qui n'aurait
aucun lien avec le meurtre de la jeune
femme